as we restart our Eurogroup meeting this  evening there will be a lot at stake I'm  calling all finance ministers to agree  to a bold and ambitious plan to shield  our economies in response to this common  threat a safety net for Europe to  protect our workers our businesses and  our nation's finances a plan that gives  us hope to overcome this crisis as we  deep into recession we are in this  together all in lock down with causality  is rising by the hour and no end in  sight every day we are reminded that  this virus is blind blind to our flags  to gender to color or social class there  are no first-class passengers we either  sink or swim together this is a true  emergency this is global the good news  is that we are very close to an  agreement I trust I still trust that  this time we will all rise to the  occasion and show the necessary spirit  of compromise which is the bedrock of  our union